انا سفاره بلجيكيه طالبتنا اقامتنا خلصت
بشهر 12 ما قدرناش نطلع نجددها ممكن ما
يدخلونا الدوله ثاني جمعتنا راحت مش
عارفين ايش حتصرف
معنا احنا اصلا من سكان الشمال اضطرينا
نزح على الجنوب عشان نقدر نطلع على المقبر
نضلنا رايحين جايين قعدنا بالشمال 40 يوم
بعد 40 يوم
طلعنا على الجنوب مش عارفه يعني نعمل او
هذا عشان نطلع قالنا ادفعوا 7000 دولار
جربنا ندفعه جينا قالوا نا لا ما بيزبط مش
حنطلع ضربوا المعبد او سكر المعبد من
الناحيه المصريه بطلوا
يطلعوا مسافر فما قدرنا احنا نطلع اوليه
الحرب وهلا لما يجي التنسيق انه الثاني
7000 دولار بيجي حكنا صعب صعب مش حنقدر
نطلع كل يوم تعال كمان كم من يوم كل يوم
بحال كل يوم
بشي
انا الدكتور ايهاب علي صالح
مخيمر مصر
الجنسيه كنت كنت عايش في غزه وطلعت بس
باوع مافيش معايا مصاري مافيش معايا ولا
اي حاجه بقي شهرين ونص قاعد في المعبر ولا
في حد بيسال علينا يا جماعه بدنا نسافر
احنا بنموت انا كل يوم بالليل خط في
الدلفي هذا كل شويه في ضرب فهم ازاي انا
ممكن تيجي قذيفه اموت انا وعيالي هيبقى في
دم مين اصلا حق النازح دوليه ان يوم لما
عاوز ينزح المفروض ينزح بحريه انا هذا انا
مش شايفه انا ولا في اكل ولا شرب وفي
المعبر في الصحرا بنتي عمرها لاث سنين
سقعانه وكل شويه بجيب لها
دوا صباح محمود الاروادي انا من لبنان كنت
مقيمه بتركيا وجينا زياره عند اهل زوجي
انا لبنانيه الاصل يعني انا واولادي
ومقيمين بتركيا كنا مسجلين بالسفر باخر
عشره بابو خضرا يعني هون ناشت السفاره
بعثت لهم ايميل ب 7/11 بسبب الحرب ما
قدرنا
نطلع يعني بقي تقريبا حصير ثلاث شهور انا
بعتي للسفاره بقولوا لي الموافقه المصريه
تمام ناطرين بس التشيك الامني على اسمائنا
وتنزل اسمائنا بالسفر بنجي هون على المعبر
قولوا لنا ما بنقدر نطلعكم الا لما يجي
كشف من مصر عشان تطلعوا نحن للاسف قنا 20
يوم يعني ما في مكان انه ننام فيه ما في
مكان معين بس بقى لنا كم يوم هون بالمعبر
بس ما في عننا حدا ابدا ب حتى يعني قنا
اربع شهور نحن برا بيوتنا عبد الرحمن ايمن
البرعاوي
سكان شمال غزه نزحنا من الشمال للجنوب
بحجه انه الاحتلال بقولنا انه نتوجه الى
مناطق امنه طبعا بعد ما توجهنا الى الجنوب
قررنا انه نمزح لمعبر رفح البري ونقدم
للسفاره اللي احنا منها دوله سيراليون
الجنوب الغربي لافريقيا طبعا احنا صار لنا
شهرين مقدمين للسفر وما زلنا معلقين في
المعبر ما يقارب 40 يوم بنام في في ظروف
صعبه جدا من البرد اي الظروف المعيشيه
الصعبه طبعا احنا معلقين من الجانب
الفلسطيني وننتظر انه نطلع من الصاله
الفلسطينيه للجانب المصري بحيث انه
يستقبلنا سفير
السيراليوني لا في حياه ولا في اكل ولا
شرب زي الناس بسخن ميه لابني حتى يعني
احميه اعمل له اكل في الاخر الميه اندلقت
علي انحرقت يعني انا عندي حرق من الدرجه
الثانيه ومعيش الا الطفل انا وابني لحالنا
قاعدين يعني ليش ما يقفوا في حالتي زوجي
كل يوم بروح على السفاره بروح على
الخارجيه كل يوم بقولوا له اعمل طلب
استعجال لامتى مرميين في البرد في الموت
في السجعه كل يوم بيقول يا رب يطلع علينا
الصبح
بخير
[تصفيق]
i